[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today up next
we have Dylan in Indianapolis hey Dylan
welcome to the
show hey guys thanks for having me
absolutely how can we
help well um I'm 20 years old uh College
Dropout and I put myself in kind of I
would say a decent amount of debt at 20
which I'm not very proud of I owe about
70k in loans and I just I mean I stress
every day about it when I wake up so I'm
just trying to see you guys' view on how
I should start attacking my loan okay
and how I can pay off my debt okay
what's the debt
in well um I have
32k in a one semester of student
loans and then I have wait one semester
where'd you go to school on
Mars I went to a private Christian
School in uh Minneapolis but one
semester was 32,00
,000 yes
sir so their total annual is 64 Grand
per year oh my go yes okay that's okay
Dylan that's okay we're gonna keep
moving We're Gonna Keep On Moving what
else what else you got it's already
happened um I'm not very proud of this
one but I actually 36k on a car LW okay
we can get rid of that that's okay what
else and then I have a personal loan for
like
3700 okay what was that
for um well basically when I dropped out
of college um I start I bought I got a
job in car sales and I needed a place to
live in Minneapolis that was like in a
safe area and that's how much the market
rent was1 1570 and then I had some
income problems of that job so I moved
to Indianapolis with my roommate and I
had to buy all B Le okay uh so what are
you doing now for
work um I still do Car Sales okay and
how much are you making
um making less than what I owe monthly
yeah because of uh interest rates are
tough right now
right well I I was blessed to have a
good interest rate on my uh loans my uh
no no no I'm saying people aren't buying
cars right
now um well I mean kind of Hit or Miss
to be honest how much will you make this
year how much will you how much will you
make this year my base salary is 24,000
and I make maybe a th000 a month in
commission okay you quit that job
tomorrow you're not making enough money
yeah you're making 36 you could I
literally took my son to breakfast the
other day and I drove past a sign it was
my daughter drove past a sign and it
said McDonald's starting $20 an hour
your car salesman Days Are Over you're
not good at that you've done it two
different places and you don't make
enough money to eat you got to let that
dream
go all right and you got to work at
McDonald's all day and then deliver
pizzas at night and drive Uber into the
morning like you're broke broke broke
broke
is that fair how much how much do you
how much would the car sell for
Dylan um well I had some negative equity
in my last car so I kind of carried over
to the new loan when I bought this car
how much okay um so the car is probably
worth about like 27 in the market right
now by 30 35 something okay
so uh yeah I mean I
would I mean I I would I would take out
a loan of like 15 pay off the 36 get a
cheap car there's no way they give him
15 though you you do what I don't think
anybody's G to give him a loan for 15
I'll get the personal loan out could you
go could you go to a credit credit union
and get a loan for 15,000
bucks I mean I'd barely get one by I
couldn't even get one for like the 3,000
without my dad cosigning yeah without
the coig I think there's no way well I'm
just trying to figure out how to get
because you your car loan is what you
make a
year it's yeah so we got to figure out a
plan to get that to get that out of your
life um where's your
family uh my family lives in Michigan
okay is that a safe place for you to go
live for a
while uh I would say so yes yeah because
here here's the deal you're gonna need
some support around you Dylan and you're
20 okay so I want to give you some Grace
you're a kid I mean yeah yeah no the mad
at you hear is that that the systems
that surround an 18 to 19yearold allowed
you a kid just trying to do what
everyone's telling you to do you got to
go get a nice car you got to get a good
sales job you got to go to this college
that cost
$334,000 or whatever it was a semester
you got to go do this stuff and you
can't afford it and they let you do that
and I I'm just sick to my stomach but
they let you do that man so Dylan what
the best thing that you can do right now
is your income that side of the equation
because you probably don't have many
expenses I'm I'm I'm assuming not you're
renting and you're going to be living on
nothing you're not going to have a life
and I would I would probably move close
to where you have a support system with
some family if nothing's keeping you in
Indianapolis uh I would consider that
but I would I Dylan I mean I would be
working 80 hours 80 hours a week I'd be
getting up and I'd be somewhere at 6:00
a.m. and I would be getting home at 9:00
p.m. I mean you're going to be exhausted
but Dylan you're 20 years old you can do
it you don't have you don't have kids at
home you don't have a wife I mean like
this is the season this is the season to
do it to absolutely go nuts cuz it's the
only part of the equation that's
actually going to give you some level of
grounding and hopefully after a year of
that of proving some level of income
then maybe you can get out of this car
loan I want this car loan out quickly uh
because it's not it's not worth it and
so whatever you have to do to be able to
say hey what can I do to qualify to sell
this and get it out because I think
that's going to that's the only piece of
this that's going to be able to relieve
some level of pressure that you can get
out so I would be I would be taking on
two to three jobs and again you're not
gonna have a life Dylan but I think that
for a season you're going to be able to
to to to knock some of this out because
um and the other great thing Dylan that
just encouraged you that you're learning
this at 20 years old people call this
show and they're 45 that have you know a
situation like this yeah no retirement
so this is your moment Dylan of saying
like what I did isn't working it's not
working and so I will never again find
myself in this position if I don't have
the money I don't care if it's for
school I don't care if it's for a car if
I don't have the money I'm not buying it
like this needs to be a point in your
story Dylan that you look back and you
say at 20 years old I did some dumb
stuff took me a little bit to get out of
it some hard work but I got out of it
and and that was it that that's the last
time you know this because Dylan if you
get this all straightened up you're at
especially at your age like this is
where you're like I you could build some
serious wealth in the future but not
with these habits and not with this
mindset they used to
have does that make sense if you were my
friend if you were my friend Dylan I
would tell you to see about having a
hard conversation with my mom and dad
and I say hard it probably be easy but
an embarrassing one and say I need to
move in for a year and I'm going to try
to make
$40,000 and if I have a year with no
bills and I make $40,000 and I take home
28 of that um I can start making a dent
in some of these things
yeah I currently live in my my room man
I pay about 400 a month for my part of
the rent and your water and your
electric and your
food yeah it's about five
525 for all of your bills plus
food uh not that's not included food I
pay about 60 bucks every two weeks for
food no
way yeah I'm I don't I don't eat a lot
I'm paying attention so you let's say
you have you say 700 dollars total which
I don't fully believe but I'll give it
to you um and you make a thousand bucks
a month at your
job I make about 2,000 base salary and
about a th000 extra commission okay so
what's your take-home every
month uh this month would be
2700 that's after taxes and
everything yeah okay are you able to pay
minimum payments on all of this are you
able to put a dent into the student loan
keep up with the car
payment yeah I actually have never
missed a pay it yet but I'm getting to
the point now where like I feel like I
might miss a payment and I'm afraid
because my father co-signed most of
these loans and I don't want to ruin his
credit because of my poor yeah that's a
fair uh weight to carry for sure so yeah
Dylan I think life just looks really
different and I and I'm sorry for that
because I think there's maybe something
you had in your head of what this is
going to be and it's probably not for a
season and by a season like 3 or four
years well I was going to say and map
out Dylan that like the end game like
like look at all of your payments look
at all of this and what John's saying
even if you go scorched Earth and you
and you literally don't pay for anything
and you say hey Mom and Dad for a year
can I live with you guys like start to
map out a plan to say okay it's going to
take me three years and then that is
that's able to be sustainable if it's
just this this idea that I'm going to
have to live like this forever and ever
it you can start to be demotivated so
have a game plan map this out as more
detailed as possible and then don't go
back in Dylan don't go back in